[Music]
all right guys
i'm here in west palm beach florida and
i'm here with skeeter which is the
captain
and owner of south florida fishing and
hunting outfitters
and today we are going to be shooting
iguanas this is a really
unique experience but also it highlights
a big problem here in south florida
and the government has now asked
homeowners
and to shoot them and kill them and
they're just really trying to do what
they can
to get those populations under control
because they are going
bonkers here but we're going to do our
part we're going to shoot some iguanas
and then we're going to take them home
and eat them and i'm excited to see what
happens and joining us on this trip
will be drake the iguana dog
we're going to go on a hunting guys
soon drink soon we will get the iguanas
hunting with dogs is like taking your
kids they're just so flipping excited it
makes it
so much more fun there's like a little
three foot iguana on the tips of these
branches right here
i'm gonna see if i can grab them by hand
we don't want to shoot it because
this is a park and you don't want to be
shooting pellet guns around how to be
responsible
[Music]
there's just a whole bunch of them in
that tree that's crazy
all right our first iguana siding not
our last
on safety just make good we've been here
10 minutes and we've already seen five
iguanas i remember a time when coming to
florida and seeing an iguana in the wild
was a rare thing
you look around for these iguanas and
you see one and then you start seeing
two
and three then four i mean they're just
it seems like they're everywhere
oh i see them will it not come from
oh you may probably jam oh he got him
there we go oh see more in there
that dog's up in there three iguanas
come piling out
drake let's go boy good iguana dog
come here come here right here here here
good boy
good boy look at this
thing it looks like a dragon he's got
this flappy bit here and
little spines look at these
claws holy mackerel
you know hitting an iguana from this
distance when everything's still is not
too bad
when the boat's going up and down the
wind's pushing us around
it's challenging you got to be a little
bit more instinctual and less like
shooting at a range
there's a good one right there where
right there on the banks
i'll tell you what guys this is
challenging but there are so
many iguanas around here we're just
seeing them everywhere
it's only the ones that hold still out
in the open that we're taking shots at
all right guys there's another invasive
species those are egyptian geese
the population of those are exploding
down here in south florida as well
one of the reasons why it's important to
keep the iguana population down is
because of their burrows
and you can see all up and down these
canals they're digging the burrows
which causes erosion and different
problems as well
so there's a couple guys up here with
long poles with nooses on it and these
guys are paid contractors that are
paid by land owners to come and remove
the iguana infestations just like you'd
pay an exterminator the difference
between us and them
is is i'm paying to do it and they're
getting paid to do it
just in that one person's backyard
there's five iguanas i can see right now
six there's another one
so i mean they're just thick in here
oh that's too high ain't gonna make
nobody happy
yeah there we go look at that guy
what a dinosaur look at this oh look at
the side that fills the cooler man
well there you go another big one check
it out got my iguana scars
all right there's a big iguana on the
bank over here
yeah i should have gotten closer
we're going to go ahead and skin these
iguanas and take them home and cook them
and i'm going to show you guys how to
cook up
iguana curry so all you're really going
to eat off of this guy
is this not really much anything going
on there
[Music]
like a pair of frog legs right there
there you go
nice little chunk of iguana tail
oh skeeter i had a great time thanks for
taking these yes sir
listen if you guys are in south florida
and you want to catch iguanas and
peacock bass and all this wonderful
stuff
check out south florida fishing and
hunting outfitters i'll put a link down
in the video description below
that was a load of fun and honestly i'm
anxious to try these out and taste these
things
hi guys
you guys want to see the iguanas yeah
yeah look at this big bertha
that's uh one two three four five ten
iguanas that's gonna make a lot of
iguana curry
what an interesting day every time i
come down here to florida i learn
something new
and see something new and it's just
amazing well that was fun but i think i
need to get in the kitchen and start
worrying about dinner i've got some
iguanas to cook up
now you notice how my tandoori iguana is
not
red most of the restaurants add a little
bit of red dye
to make that really bright red barbecue
look on their tandoori chicken
i just left it out because i really
don't care what color they are
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we got some tikka masala
[Applause]
[Applause]
you're a little nervous about it aren't
you i'm totally nervous
okay grab a plate and we will take this
journey
together okay
actually that's pretty good i can tell
it's if you over
did this it would get chewy in a hurry
but i think i got
lucky and i didn't overcook it but they
have tailbones
no this is the this is the tail do you
like the iguana yeah
but it's like okay but when you dip it
in and then
dip it in the rice it tastes so good so
you like the curry but you're not so
sure about the iguana meat yeah
the iguana legs i cooked in the pan are
a lot chewier than the ones i cooked in
the oven so
you know learned a little something
there so not over cooking it appears to
be a big deal
but you know still good though yeah
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching